okay so now we're told that the two
cameras outside of Jeffrey Epstein cell
on the night that he killed himself
malfunctioned on the very night of his
alleged suicide Reuters is reporting
this now the cameras are being sent to
the FBI to investigate why do they both
malfunction um I'm not sure why they're
being investigated I mean there's
nothing suspicious here at all this is
very I have been repeatedly informed
repeatedly informed that it's ridiculous
and irresponsible to engage in
conspiracy theories about this there's
there's nothing to nothing to see here
really it's just a totally normal thing
there's no reason for any conspiracy
theorist Epstein was a global sex
trafficker with damning information on
very powerful people who was taken off
suicide watches and broke his own neck
with a bedsheet while his to prison
guard slept in two cameras outside of
cells simultaneously malfunction I mean
there's nothing weird about that why
would you get suspicious it's it's it's
it's all this kind of thing happens
every day all right if I had a dime for
every time this kind of thing has
happened I would have enough money to
buy a piece of hard candy in 1950 I mean
what's the other option here honestly
what what I mean that it's either all
this stuff is a coincidence and he
killed himself so that's the logical
option or what that one of his
extraordinarily powerful child rapist
friends arranged for his murder in order
to cover their tracks come on does that
sound like the kind of thing a child
rapist would do let's be real about this
you know he happen to have a lot of
friends who again very powerful very
wealthy politically connected they rape
children and so but does that mean that
they would then do something as horrible
as killing Jeffrey I mean just think
about it for a second let's not be
absurd about this besides killing a
witness who might testify against you
now that never happens that that's
except for in Hollywood movies all right
so yeah you've seen movies where they do
that but that's that's Hollywood stunt
in real life okay it's not like they
have entire programs like witness
protection in place specifically because
this sort of thing happens all time no
no that's it that doesn't exist either I
Got News for you that's that's all in
the movies it is way way way more likely
that the jail just happened to
coincidentally transfer Epstein cellmate
to a different cell and take him off
suicide watch while his guards who
instantly fell asleep and the cameras
all constantly malfunction right as
Epstein was breaking his own neck in
multiple places with a bedsheet tied to
a bump it that's way more likely then
that you know some powerful friends paid
off couple people and arranged for his
murder I what I think my which requires
more I just just stop okay should be
reasonable that's all that's all I'm
gonna say about this tired of all the
conspiracy theories alright um there's a
lot of other things to talk about though
but before we get to that I want to tell
you about our friends over at expressvpn
now admit it when it comes to cyber
crime that's the kind of thing where you
think it happens to other people it's
not going to happen to you and because
what you think well nobody wants your
data it's it's you know you're not a
you're not a the kind of person people
are coming after or that hackers can't
grab your passwords your credit card
details but with all that I'm afraid to
say it I'm not trying to fear monger
here but with all of that confidence it
is misplaced fact is stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money if you if you
use public Wi-Fi if you ever use the
public Wi-Fi you've been at Starbucks
you've been somewhere plugged into the
Wi-Fi I mean we've all done it on an
airplane whatever well then you're
you're exposed and there's a there's
it's very easy for it but you wouldn't
even need a very talented hacker to get
in and get your information when you
leave your internet connection
unencrypted your basic you might as well
be writing your password and your credit
card numbers up on a billboard somewhere
for them to see it's really as easy as
that so that's why to protect myself
from cyber criminals I use expressvpn
expressvpn secures and makes anonymous
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address expressvpn has easy-to-use apps
so it's you know you don't need to know
a lot about this kind of stuff I don't
but that's why I just hand it over to
expressvpn
and it all runs seamlessly in the
background of your computer your phone
your tablet takes care of business you
don't need to worry about it protect
your online activity today and find out
how you can get three months for you to
Express VPN dot-com slash Walsh that's e
XP our ESS VPN dot-com slash walls for
three months free with a one-year
package visit Express VPN dot-com slash
Walsh alright now that I've been laid
all the conspiracy theories about
Jeffrey Epstein I want to let's let's
begin by talking about this Dave
Chapelle thing as you've probably heard
Dave Chappelle has a new comedy special
standard special out on Netflix came out
on Sunday night or Monday I believe and
it's generated quite a lot of outrage
from the woke mob quite a lot now
they're outraged about everything all
the time they're in a perpetual state of
constant outrage of course so it all
sort of bleeds together but this has
been even more heightened than usual and
why are they upset well because Dave
Chappelle is not attempting to be a
progressive comedian he's just a
comedian and he tells jokes and he tells
stories and he gives his opinion without
any concern for how it will be received
or or whether people will agree and
these days that's enough to make you
public enemy number one that's that's
enough to put you in the metaphorical
crosshairs that's all that's all it
takes and the other thing about Dave
Chappelle in this special and in general
that he actually goes after sacred cows
in our culture I think there are a lot
of comedians who get credit for being
brave and for saying things other people
won't say but then when you actually
listen to them they're saying the same
stuff everybody says and what they're in
their comedy is very very safe it may
ruffle feathers but it's not going to
ruffle it's gonna ruffle the right
people's feathers in other words could
ruffle the feathers of people who can't
can't do you any harm
uh Chappell doesn't do that I mean he's
going after he spends time in this
comedy special talking about the the
LGBTQ camp and he goes into an extended
riff on it now progressives will tell
you that well that's not brave at all
that's that's that's punching down no
it's not it's it's really not that's the
kind of thing that ruins people's
careers that that is the unmentionable
that that's that's the unspeakable stuff
you're not allowed to do that anymore to
tell jokes about the LGBT folks you're
you can tell jokes about anybody else
but not then I mean anyone have they're
the ones you're not allowed to touch
anymore
and and that's the fact but he does and
so that that takes courage whether you
agree or not it doesn't matter and this
is part of what comedy is supposed to be
if you if you as a comedian if you
identify an area that where it seems
like people aren't allowed to tell jokes
so you identify a group that people
aren't allowed to joke about
then you joke about it for that reason
simply because you're not allowed to
that's part of what what that's part of
the service that comedians provide
historically now I watch the special
myself I'll say that I'll say that the
special is outrageously inappropriate
and offensive he makes a number of very
off-limit jokes the humor is very dark
at certain points he jokes about things
that that you're not supposed to joke
about it could get very morbid at other
points it's also hilarious and it's
brilliant and I think that it's the most
important comedy special over the last
twenty years easily I think it's it's
it's historic in some ways not to
overstate it but but just that in in in
being a sort of broadside against PC
culture that's what makes it important
and I don't say that because I agree
with everything he said I don't I
disagree I disagree strongly
with some of it but but but who cares
okay I don't watch comedy so that I can
agree with it that's not the point that
would be a very boring reason to watch
comedy to sit down and and you know
watch a comedy routine simply because
you want to hear your own opinions
spouted back to you okay that's what
cable news shows exist for unfortunately
that's not what comedians are supposed
to do but that's apparently why many
leftists watch comedy and that's why
they hate Dave Chappelle now and there
have been a lot of long think pieces and
left-wing publications about how
terrible it is and so on let me read
just one example this is a review and
vice about of the Dave Chappelle special
I'm not going to be the whole thing I'll
read a few bits and pieces of this and
it begins you can definitely skip Dave
Chappelle's new Netflix special sticks
and stones you can so we're giving
thankfully Vice is giving us permission
they're saying you could skip this one
not just you can you you must is this is
permission but also at an instruction
you're not so this you're not allowed to
find funny this is not funny but then
it's good goes on the comedian doubles
doubles down on misogyny and transphobia
and both the special and the hidden
bonus scenes that follow Dave Chappelle
made a return to Netflix Monday with a
new stand-up special sticks and stones
fans quickly realized that if you watch
until the very end the special is a
secret epilogue called the punch line
where Chappelle answers questions from
audience members who want who want to
who went to his separate Dave Chapelle
on Broadway stand-up show last July the
special takes the comics anti woke miss
stick to a new level and the whole thing
is repetitive and exhausting enough that
it's a slog to even make it to the QA at
one point is routine he says he doesn't
believe Michael Jackson molested young
children this time which I disagree
strongly with that but again that's not
why I'm watching a comedy special this
time those jokes included asking the
audience how funny would be
he was actually a Chinese person stuck
inside a black man's body and that would
be kind of funny which you guessed it
also included a racist impression of a
Chinese person he also finds which which
can I stop right there it's not racist
because Chinese is not a race he also
found time to defend fellow
controversial comedians Kevin Hart and
louis c.k painting them as victims of an
overzealous call-out culture can I just
sort of stop here again it's a call
Kevin Hart a controversial comedian
Kevin Hart
he's if that's what qualifies as a
controversial comedian then and the word
controversial just has no meaning by the
time the Q&A plays at the end of special
Chappelle has already shown his
unapologetic approach to courting
controversy his answers put that into
even starker view he's talking about
transgender people Chappelle has always
been a daredevil comedian willing to
take a controversial stance or downplay
a serious controversy for laughs
including how dare he I mean these he's
he's downplaying controversies for
laughs that's not what comedians are
supposed to do you're telling he's out
there trying to get laughs how dare he
but now he chooses to blatantly ignore
the historic criticism against his style
of cottom comedy and new loud and clear
criticism from the trans community his
approach comes off like a defiant
rejection of change at any cost
and he keeps going down this path
drawing attention to the worst acts pet
aspects of his important career the
biggest cost will be tarnishing his own
legacy I mean it is he's up there
ignoring the credit we have clearly told
him that he stopped he's supposed to
stop saying these things but he keeps
saying them he's ignoring us I mean he
was criticized by the trans community
and he hasn't stopped this is outrageous
this is what these people left us they
they really I mean if they
they can't wrap their head around if
they tell you to stop saying something
or that it is it's offensive and you
keep saying it they just they can't even
get their head around it they're they're
like what do you can't do this we don't
like it
oh and here's a here's a good bit from a
BuzzFeed article titled Dave Chappelle's
new Netflix special is unnecessarily
offensive
he says Chappelle still wants it both
ways he was willing to address
criticisms of his earlier sets that were
more flagrantly lazily anti-trans but
not actually apologize or admit to
changing his mind or express any
meaningful empathy in his 2017 special
equanimity he talks about receiving a
letter from a white trans fan who
received who criticized his transphobia
using the remark to essentially make
more tired anti-trans jokes and in a
surprise epilogue to sticks and stones
he tells another story about Daphne a
trans woman who attended several of his
sets in San Francisco they chatted at
the bar and Daphne thanked him for
normalizing transgenders the audience at
Radio City Music Hall were Chappelle
told a story applauds loudly it's
cringe-inducing such a blatantly cynical
familiar move out of the old I have a
marginalized friend so I can make this
joke playbook what is especially
frustrating about Chappelle's trans
jokes is how he essentially acts as if
black trans people don't exist and as if
black trans women in particular aren't
more likely to be victims of violence
his truth to power comedy only works if
he acts as though trans people and black
people are wholly separate entities it's
enough to make you want to tie a pail to
a chair and force him to binge watch
episodes of Poe's oh man these people
are they are such self parodies that's
another reason why it's I think it's
brilliant that Chappelle is able to make
funny jokes about them because it's
actually it's so easy in some in some
ways
it's so easy to make jokes about them
that it's hard because the jokes are so
when you have someone who's making a
parody of themselves how do you make a
joke that's gonna be funnier than what
they're already doing how do you make an
observation aside from just look at that
look at what they're doing but
Chappelle's
able to do that because again this is
comedy do you know what comedy is left
us do you know what it is I mean it's a
sincere question do you actually know
what it is do you understand the point a
lecture about trans inclusiveness which
is what both of these articles seem to
want would not be very funny now whether
or not we agree with it it wouldn't be
funny it's just not it would be like if
I got offended that Chappelle wasn't up
there preaching about how Jesus Christ
is our Lord and Savior now I believe
that he is our Lord saver but that's
that's not comedy that wouldn't be there
wouldn't be a funny thing for him to do
so it just it wouldn't make any sense in
the context now left-wing gender theory
as it happens you know is a ridiculous
thing and so there are many jokes to be
made about it and that's why he makes
the jokes and the fact that everyone in
society pretends to take it seriously
means that those funny things should be
pointed out because that's what
comedians are supposed to do that's the
job of a comedian to tell jokes and
again especially if you're you know the
important comedians are gonna tell jokes
about things that you're not supposed to
joke about meanwhile a lot of people are
talking about this bit from Chappelle's
special Chappelle's special s'appelle
special as I just put it so let's let's
let's take a look at this that would be
real with you and I don't know buddy
because what I think anyway I'm not for
abortion oh shut up
[Applause]
I'm not for it but I'm not against it
either it all depends on who I get
pregnant and ladies to be fair to us I
also believe if you decide to have the
baby a man should not have to pay
that's fair if you can kill this mother
I can at least abandon them it's my
money my choice
okay now his his his overall point and
there was it was a longer bit than that
and I wouldn't have time plays a little
thing but his overall point about
abortion I don't agree with it's obvious
that he's you know I I think I think
some conservatives and pro lifers are
overstating the case by saying that you
know Apelles a pro-lifer and this was a
I don't it's pretty clear to me that
he's not but he does take the
pro-abortion argument to its logical
conclusion and he and he he points out a
very important inconsistency in the
pro-abortion position which is that look
if in and I've made this point myself
many times though I'm not Dave Chappelle
so nobody cares but if we're saying that
a mother has no duty has no
responsibility to her own child if
that's what we're saying and that's that
is what the pro-abortion people are
saying and this is one of the reasons
why I think on the pro-life side one of
our main arguments should be it's it's
not even right to life you know the baby
has a has a right to exist although the
baby does have a right to exist but I
think in some ways the more important
argument to make is about the
responsibility of the mother so we could
talk all day about rights what are
rights you know in rights are can
sometimes be more AB even more abstract
more difficult to pin down especially
these days it's become a sort of muddled
concept and everything is a right these
days but responsibility that's different
and the basic concept that we as parents
have a special responsibility to our own
child that's a concept that everyone
it's a very clear everyone understands
that nobody disagrees with it actually
in principle now people want to make
exceptions for unborn children but when
it comes to born children everyone agree
yeahyou of course you have a special
responsibility to your own child but if
if we're saying that mule you could kill
your chucks you don't want your child
then that means of course you have no
responsibility to that child the mother
doesn't and if the mother has no
responsibility to that child then
neither does the father and so if the
mother says you know what okay I I want
to keep the kid she could have she could
have gone either way it's totally up to
her so that the the father not only has
no responsibility but he has no right no
power no say he is completely irrelevant
that's what we're always told that the
men need to shut up they have no say in
this if nothing to do with it no uterus
no opinion well if that's true men have
nothing to do with this nothing to say
about it their opinion doesn't matter
they have no rights no responsibility if
that's true then then if if the woman
decides to have the baby she's on her
own I guess you can't all of a sudden
say okay you know what actually I'm
gonna keep the baby so ya know you'd you
you need to have a lot to say now now
this is neither now now you're yeah now
now this is your concern because I
decided that it is no no no no no if
you're gonna make the argument that hey
it's her body she could make a choice
okay but she can't make choices for the
man cuz that's not it that's that's
that's not her body if you're going to
say that men should be legally required
to take care of their own children which
I that's what I believe I agree I think
parents should be legally required both
parents should be legally required to
take care of their own kids unless
they're gonna put the kid up for
adoption but if we're gonna say that
then that means that what you're telling
me is that a man has a responsibility to
his child
which-which fine I agree good but if a
man has
responsibility to his child then
obviously the mother does too and if the
mother has a responsibility to her child
then at a minimum that responsibility
must mean that she's not allowed to kill
him so as Chappelle puts it look if I
can't abandon him then why are you
allowed to kill him all right speaking
of let's see do we want to do this maybe
we'll save that yeah we'll save that for
the fertile say that one for one for
tomorrow because I had something else I
wanted to talk about this is a report of
the daily wire says earlier this week a
video of u.s. national soccer team star
Carli Lloyd Lloyd kicking a 55 year old
55 yard field goal went viral
her trainer James galantis told Fox
Sports that one NFL team had expressed
interest in hiring her galantis told Fox
reporter Martin Rodgers today she got
another call from another NFL team the
one that that called today I don't want
to say what was was willing to put her
on the roster for the next game there
would be a preseason game galantis
continued saying anyway that she thinks
that she'd be a great field goal kicker
now Lloyd is saying she's considering
the idea she spoke with Jeff's kovarsky
of ABC six Philadelphia on Wednesday and
he asked this has been coming up a lot
how much do you continue to think about
pursuing an NFL job
Lloyd answered yeah it's been something
that's turned into a casual day out at
the Eagles practice just hitting some
field goals and then she talks about how
she's considering all of these different
offers and and I don't know if I read
that part but this is a she's a she's 38
years old I believe Carli Lloyd and now
she's saying that she's considering
offer allegedly she's been getting
offers from NFL teams and and now we
might get our first female field goal
kicker and I've seen I've seen people
online
cheering this and say ah wouldn't that
be great and we'd have our
first female NFL player would be
historic and so on I'll just tell you as
somebody who watches football avidly and
it's become very apparent to me that
many of the people chiming in on this
topic haven't watched it at all
as someone watches football III agree
that having a female NFL player even a
kicker
would be historic but one of the reasons
why would be historic is that it would
probably lead to the first-ever death on
an NFL field I mean you put a woman on
an NFL field as a player and she will
literally get killed out there I mean
she will literally die and that's I'm
not it's not a joke not exaggerating
that really will happen
you put a 38 year old 140 pound soccer
playing female on an NFL field with a
bunch of 300-pound muscle-bound men who
can run a 40-yard dash and you know 4.5
seconds if the 300 pounds they probably
probably before like 4.7 seconds 4.8 but
still the point is they're very fast you
put you you combine those things and she
her life is in danger now even for those
250 300-pound men their lives are in
danger I mean there are even just this
this in the last week or two there have
been two male football players who
retiring from the league because their
bodies can't handle the abuse anymore
these were all-star players Gronkowski
and Andrew Luck so you put this woman on
the field I mean this is this is such a
terrible idea I don't think it will
actually happen at least not yet
probably eventually it will I think
eventually the NFL is going to give in
to it's politically correct urges as it
has a tendency to do and it's gonna
pressure one of these teams to put it to
to hire a female kicker and it's going
to be a terrible disastrous
idea that I don't want to see happen and
not because I don't want to see women
playing football because I'm a sexist
although I have no interest in watching
women play football because they just
aren't very good at it but that's not
the issue it's I don't want to see a
woman get killed on the field and that
is what will happen it is what will
happen absolutely terrible idea first of
all couple things here first of all
again not taking anything away from from
what's her name Carly Carly Loyd not
taking anything away from her but just
because you can drill a 55 year old 55
yard field goal in practice that doesn't
mean you can do it in a game at game
speed with pads on that's that's there's
one problem here is that she's not
wearing pads when she does this and she
also doesn't have a bunch of NFL
defensive lineman bearing down on her
so just cuz you can do it at practice
doesn't mean you could do it on in in
the NFL and aside from that yeah I mean
kickers are not taking the same physical
abuse that a linebacker is gonna take or
running backs in a take or even a
quarterback is going to take but the
fact is if you're a kicker you're you're
on a and you're playing a game you're
you're in the middle of the action and
you're gonna you're going to absorb some
contact if you play long enough unless
injuries knock you out before then if
you play long enough you're going to
absorb a lot of contact even as a kicker
kickers have to be able to at least
attempt to make a tackle if they get a
blocked kick or if there's a busted play
and on a busted play the kicker can get
tackled if there's a busted play two
kickers got to pick up the ball and run
with it
they can get they can get laid out and
defensive players love that they love
the chance to tackle the kicker on
kickoffs now assuming she'd be handling
kickoff duties - unless unless you're
gonna have a team that has her just
doing field goals and hires a separate
person to do kickoffs which will be a
total waste of a roster spot you get a
you only get 53 men on a game day roster
to give one of those up for an extra
kicker is just not something that I
think I need a whole team's we're gonna
want to do so assuming she's handling
kickoff duties - then she's got to run
down the field you have a 140-pound
and running down the field on a special
teams play full-speed as she's got
blockers coming right at her again 250
pound men and they're only G's our
special teams player their only job if
you're on the if you're on the kick
return team and you're not receiving the
ball and you're a block or your job is
to pick someone on that field that's
coming at them and just lay them out
that's what your job is and these guys
love doing it you're gonna put a woman
in that environment just absolute it's
not even funny because of the result
which would be brutal so no this is I
again I agree that probably eventually
this will happen and it I mean it might
destroy the NFL there's not a lot that
could bring down the NFL behemoth but a
woman getting killed on the field might
do it so for Carli Lloyd's sake I hope
that this this doesn't pan out all right
let's go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail
accounts from James says dear Matt I've
I'm a recent follower of you and other
daily wire wire errs if you will no
please if you won't why ours it's a
difficult word to say I've thoroughly
enjoyed hearing your various takes on
monitor issue so far co-run i co run an
ask blog on tumblr where I pretend to be
video game characters answering letters
from real-life fans I don't know what
that means I James I don't know what I
just read i co run okay I understand
that Co run so you're running with
someone else and asked blog what is an
ask blog I guess it's a blog where
people ask questions where I pretend
be videogame characters answering
letters from real-life in I'm sorry I
know this wasn't the point of your email
I'm just trying to figure out what's
going on here all right um
recently I've reached over 12 thousand
followers Wow
I happen to be a right-leaning Christian
so this next part shouldn't be too
surprising since I started I've been
accused of racism ableism transphobia
few other things all of which I plead
not guilty to the worst cadet can
honestly be said about me is that I've
occasionally been insensitive to be fair
that's all too easy to do nowadays what
video game characters do you pretend to
be like Mario Donkey Kong
that's how up-to-date my video game
knowledge is when I hear video games I
still think you know Super Mario World
Donkey Kong sonic since I'm sure you can
relate to false and exaggerated
accusations like these I'd like to ask
what you think is the best strategy for
finding a balance between boldness and
sensitivity in other words what's the
best way to be inclusive without being
afraid of accidentally offending someone
thanks a bunch and God bless James I'll
make this very short which is out of
character for me in these times when
trying to strike the balance between
boldness and sensitivity err on the side
of boldness that's all this is from
Thomas says hey Matt glad you got a
vacation and as an avid angler myself I
was curious when you said you went
fishing on a lake what species were you
targeting and how did how did you do I'm
partial to ensure a saltwater fish
myself but I do like to fish wherever
they're biting so I have been known to
land pike and largemouth every once a
while glad to have you back I was
fishing for largemouth mostly Tom a few
pickles you know were there so I caught
a few of those but mostly largemouth I'd
say I went you know did pretty well
largest I caught was I didn't have my
scale with me so I'm gonna say my
largest was 7 pounds but it was probably
more like 4 and then I caught a bunch of
2 pounders so nothing huge but I didn't
hit any homeruns but I was I was getting
a lot of solid singles and doubles I
guess for the week so there's a lot of
fun this is from Philip says hi Matt I
just listened to episode 3 20 with what
you're saying about affairs of
politician
and that people like that can't be trust
that I'm wondering how you'd make the
argument that anyone who agrees with
what you're saying could ever vote for
Trump or basically any other high-level
politician love your show keep up the
good work well Phillip yeah we talked
about this yesterday in regards the
thing that brought it up anyway was
Ilhan Omar this the allegations made in
court documents that she is a
homewrecker essentially that she cheated
on her own husband with a married man
and that that led to the dissolution of
the married man's marriage and and I
guess maybe allegedly her own marriage
as well and I said that you know we're
told well this is personal and it's not
any of our business and we can't make
any judgments on it's a got nothing to
do with us as voters I disagree I think
it it tells us something obviously about
a person's character if they're an
adulterer and so that is gonna have a
bearing on what we do with our vote in
my view now Trump definitely is not
exempt from this okay I'm not gonna be a
craven little wimpy coward and pretend
that you know what I'm talking about
this that Trump you know pretend I
forgot about Trump's issues I didn't
forget about them
and I would not call Trump a trustworthy
or loyal person by any stretch of the
imagination and anyone who would use
those words to describe him is just a
mindless sicko fan who you can't even
take seriously I mean the guy clearly is
not trustworthy or loyal
at all at all to anyone especially his
his his own family members
you know he's cheated on all of his
spouses all three of them repeatedly
including when they were pregnant okay
his wife is pregnant he's out cheating
on him I mean this is that speaks to his
character it just does however if you if
you survey the options and you decide
that even taking his considerable
negative character traits into account
he still
the best option of the bad options that
I think it's perfectly valid to vote for
him but yes again you can tell a lot
about a person by how they treat their
spouses you can't it's not gonna tell
you everything about them but it tells
you a lot about them this is supposed to
be the most important person in your
life and the person to whom you have
made the most important promise you will
ever make to anyone I mean you have
looked them in the eye in front of
witnesses and promised to be loyal and
faithful to them and if you're willing
to break that promise and break it
repeatedly with multiple people as Trump
as none as Clinton did then yes that
tells you a lot that tells us a lot
about you a lot but you still have to
take into consideration the diabolical
evil of his opponents and that's why I
didn't say I never said that if a
politician cheats on his wife or on her
husband we can never vote for them I
wouldn't say that
and there certainly are many examples in
history of men who were unfaithful and
were terrible husbands and terrible
fathers yet were good leaders there are
I don't even need to go into examples
because immediately 10 examples pop into
your head so there we know that that
happens in history but the point is that
those examples you can think of they
were good leaders in spite of how they
treated their family so they had these
enormous character flaws enormous I mean
if you fail as a husband and a father
then you have failed in a profound way
this is not a small detail right but for
the for the people in history who have
been great leaders even though they were
terrible family men it is again it's in
spite of that all that tells us is that
these were great people in the sense
that they just had their
there are other positive qualities were
so tremendous so significant
so overarching that it was able to
compensate even for these enormous
character flaws character defects so
well we have to ask her so with any
given politician you know you have to
take offs into account you'd say yes
this is this is an incredible character
flaw but do there other positive aspects
somehow / override it as far as voters
are concerned and then you have to look
at their opponents and you take all that
in consideration and you make your
decision but my point is simply that the
affairs and all that that you do that is
one of the things you take into
consideration it's not the only thing
but it is it is something at least no
matter what letter is next to the
person's name this is from Lindsay says
hi Matt you talked about kids napping
yesterday on your show I've always
wondered why kids hate to nap so much I
love it as an adult though I rarely get
the opportunity yeah I I think this is
one of a bunch of areas Lindsay where
where kids have the right idea um really
even though I agree with you I think
kids have the right idea I think they
probably have a better attitude about it
even though it's annoying and I can't
relate to kids not wanting to NAB like
my my two-year-old my two and a half
year old he loses his mind every time
it's time for a nap every day when it's
nap time he just loses we go up to him
you know you tell him okay buddy time
for a nap and he reacts like a man who
has just been sentenced to death it's a
it's a it's like a man in a courtroom
has been sent to death row he just he
literally falls to the ground on his
knees and throws up his hands like no no
that's what he does please don't make me
no uh and I've tried to explain to him
like buddy we are bringing you to a cool
dark room where quiet room or you can
relax for as long as you want in peace
quiet nobody will disturb you in fact
extraordinary efforts are going to be
made behind the scenes to make sure that
nobody disturbs you my wife when it
comes to you know keeping people away
from the napping baby and keeping people
wet she's like that she's like a ninja
if you walk by a room where a kid is
napping and you even cuff my wife will
like rappel down from the rafters out of
nowhere Shh baby's sleeping so that's
what is gonna happen try to explain this
to him this is what's gonna happen just
to make sure that you get peace and
quiet do you know what I would do for
that you can relax as long as you want
without being disturbed do you realize
how long it's been since I could relax
for as long as I wanted without being
disturbed I'll tell you how long it's
been okay we started having kids seven
years ago it's been seven years that's
how long it's been but he doesn't get it
and and here's my point maybe he's right
not to get it I mean can you imagine can
you really can you imagine loving being
awake
so much loving life so much that you
treat sleep like it's death itself I
mean can you imagine just being so
enthralled by existence that you never
want to close your eyes even for a
second they you break down into tears
and are traumatized by the thought of
just having to lay in your bed for a
couple of hours that you're that excited
about everything and you just want to be
awake all the time can you imagine
having that attitude as an adult I can't
because that's an adult it's exactly the
opposite you spend the whole day just
longing to go to sleep again
you wake up what's the mean you wake up
in the morning what's the first thing
you think so I can't wait to go to bed
again it's the first thing you think but
my kids they wake up and they're just
like like a rocket ship they just they
wake up in half a second later there's
running around
house they wake up and I mean they're
practical
okay my oldest son he wakes up singing I
mean he wakes up and he starts singing
within within within seconds he's
running around running around the house
singing at 6:00 a.m. that's how happy he
is to be awake I envy that I really do
it is so completely foreign to me now at
this point my life is exactly the
opposite of my attitude singing in the
morning is just something I can't even
conceive of but that's that's kids so
yeah I think and that's that's one of
the hard things about being a parent is
that there are so many things with kids
where they sort of have the right
attitude really but you have to break
them of it any way you feel like so my
kids hate going to sleep they love being
awake but I got you know if they got to
go to sleep they got to take naps they
got to sleep at night and so I have to
break them of that I basically have to
stop loving life so much I mean you
could love it but not this much just
love it a little bit less all right just
just a tiny bit less can you it's kind
of a sad thing all right um we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed Matt Walsh
show is produced by Robert Sterling
associate producer alexia Garcia del Rio
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer his Austin Stephens
edited by Donovan Fowler audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena the Matt Walsh show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 if you want to delve the
depths of leftist madness head on over
to the Michael Noel's show where we
examine what's really going on beneath
the surface of our politics and bask in
the simple joys of being right
you
[Music]